Thanks to tele shape com for sponsoring this video,
go to dollar shave club.com forward slash buy.
Grab these and get started for just $5
During a happy period of more than four score years,
the public administration was conducted by the virtue and abilities of Nerva
Trajan Hadrian.
And the two Anthony means these are the words of 18th century historian,
Edward Gibbon exemplifying the concept of the five good emperors five Roman
rulers who successfully governs the empire by absolute power under the guidance
of wisdom and virtue Hadrian was there right in the middle and left behind the
legacy of a buildup. As he traveled throughout the regions of his empire,
he founded new cities while all the existing settlements,
he encountered benefited from some kind of improvements,
whether it was a new theater, a bath house,
or even just a donation for the future.
He enacted since more policies and strengthens the position of his army is even
though he had no grounds, military ambitions,
that being said Hadrian was definitely no.
Saint people quickly fell out of his fever runs.
As you will see those who were posed or slighted him matched their violent ends.
He also cattails the powers of the Senate and leans more towards an autocratic
rule. For this reason, scholars see Hadrian as a mercurial character.
One whose outward displays of geniality and restraint could have simply been a
facade, hiding a devious and hedonistic minds,
or maybe he was just an emperor who wanted to help his people as best he could.
It really is hard to say. And for millennia,
Hadrian has been a puzzle that historians have struggled to.
[Inaudible].
Hadrian was born Cumulus Ellias Hadrianus on January the 24th,
76 a deal. Although his place of birth is still somewhat uncertain.
Although most sources indicate he was born in Italico era settlement in the
province of Spain here,
beta others have said that his family may have actually been in Rome at the time
of his birth,
which would not have been so far fetched given that his father PBLs alias
Adriana's Ava was a Roman Senate up. His mother was named Paulina,
retroactively referred to as Paulina,
the elder to help distinguish us from Hadrian's sister and his niece who both
shared the same name and other relative we should highlight in is perhaps the
most important. One of all was an uncle of Hadrian names. Marcus
[inaudible].
He is better remembered as the Roman emperor Trajan and he will play a major
role in Hadrian's life. His own reign was also quite noticeable,
perhaps the best one of all, then guess what?
We've already done a biographics video all about him. If he missed it,
why not give it to watch right now and then come back here? Well,
we'll pick up pretty much where the last one left off in 86,
80 Hadrian lost both of his parents.
It was a terrible blow for the young 10 year old boy,
but he had a modicum of good fortune.
His Trajan took him and his sister under his wing as his wards.
Ward's downstairs. Another powerful, official named [inaudible],
who was a friend of his father.
This was still over a decade before Trajan took the throne,
but he still had the money and influence to ensure that Hadrian received a good
education and then started climbing through the ranks of Roman bureaucracy.
As it was expected of him.
Hadrian ends of public service on the path to become a Roman Senator like his
father.
He started out as a lowly civil servants and then served several times as a
military Tribune. Not surprisingly when Trajan became the new emperor,
the positions held by Hadrian significantly improved,
but even so Trajan was careful not to promote him too fast.
And there was even a ten-year period when Hadrian did not rise through the ranks
at all, he served among others is Christ a Tribune, pray to a console. And,
but he was also able to indulge his passion for Greek culture.
When he traveled to Athens where he was granted citizenship and named as one of
the arch arms, the officials who handled the city's affairs
With any succession worth mentioning Hadrian's rise to the throne of Rome was
marked by intrigue violence and controversy. At the time of Trajan's death,
Rome was a war with a Parthian empire in Western Asia.
The conflict was not going in his favor.
And he also had to contend with several rebellions and other parts of his empire
in 117 ed Trajan fell ill. So he sat,
sailed back to Rome where Hadrian became the de facto commander leading the
Romans against puffier as the new governor of Syria.
Trajan never made it home though,
as he died on the journey on August the eighth now of course came the matter of
who will become the new emperor Trajan and his wife Pompei up Latina had no
children of their own and he never named a Nat no Diddy because around the time
of his death,
some letters appeared apparently written by Trajan where he named Hadrian as his
adopted son and add to the throne. So did Trajan actually write these letters?
That is the question that still troubles historians.
Many historians believe that Hadrian succession was in fact,
the work of Platina and his other guardian at yanas who both wanted Hadrian to
rule because one, they liked him and two,
because it meant they would maintain their privileged positions by the emperor's
side. And this is not a belief of only modern scholars,
ancient historians like Cassius Dio,
who is one of our main references for Hadrian said the same thing in his room
and history written less than a hundred years later,
even at a great source for his opinion,
his own father [inaudible] who served as Senator and governor of Synthesia.
Cassius DEO claims that his father established with accuracy as did other
senators,
that the succession of Hadrian had been engineered by patina as it was her
signature on the letters allegedly written by Trajan something she had never
done before.
He also sends that Platina delayed the announcement of her husband's death so
that the people most first hear of Hadrian's adoption. Surprisingly,
despite the suspicions Hadrian's Ascension to the throne when smoothly and
unopposed,
some have argued that this was because even if Trajan did not name him as his,
eh, probably it would have been okay with Hadrian becoming the next emperor.
After Royal Trajan took him on as his ward, he looks after his political career,
he arranged for Hadrian to marry.
One of his grand nieces would be as to be an errand. During times of war,
he showed that he trusted Hadrian by placing him in charge of the troops.
Furthermore, if Trajan did have someone else in mind,
he probably would have named him by then the Historia or gusta mentions a rumor
that Trajan intended to name one of Rome's leading jurists,
neuro Ts Prisco's as his successor,
but this is the only source on the matter and is generally considered to be
pretty unreal
On August the 10th, 117 80 Hadrian became the new Roman emperor.
He was still in Syria and he took his time before heading to the Capitol,
putting down some of the rebellions that had erupted during the reign of his
predecessor. He did however, write letters to the Roman Senate.
Some was boilerplate staff asking the Senate to confirm his sovereignty,
choosing an official title for himself, pledging to serve the public interests,
making arrangements for Trajan's funerals and densification and so on.
They also wanted to get on the good side to the Senate.
So he swore an oath never to put to death and he sent it to her.
He then immediately proceeded to break this oath,
or at the very least it was broken in his name.
We're not sure of the precise circumstances,
but soon after Hadrian's essential to the throne,
four of Rome's most powerful senators were accused and convicted of several
challenges, including conspiracy against him.
They were Palmer and the greeners sealers and Kratos,
none were actually in Rome at the time.
So they were convicted in absentia without a public trial and sentenced to
death. And then they were tracked down and killed.
This immediately turns to the Senate against Hadrian within amnesty.
That lasted for his entire reign. Even when he died,
the Senate wanted to deny him the divine honors it's pretty much had to be
forced to do so by a successor for his bond.
Hadrian always denied any involvement in the deaths of the four senators has
guardian and Tatiana's was almost certainly responsible,
but it remains a matter of pure speculation of whether Hadrian Newman's approved
of his actions or not given the power and influence of the four slain officials.
It would not be out of the question for,
at a yarn as to fear that they might oppose Hadrian succession,
but this is just conjecture the Historia or Gusto, which again,
contains a lot of statements that are demonstrably false claims that the four
officials can spot in a murder plot against the new emperor.
These senators were not the only prominent men slain by Hadrian.
If Cassius DEO is anything to go by,
he also accused the emperor of banishing and then putting to death,
Apple adores of Damascus, the theme doc attacked,
who was responsible for most of the landmarks built under Trajan,
including his Trump full column into the bridge, cross the Danube,
all of this because Apollo Duras and sells his Hadrian ones back when Trajan was
still emperor like mocking his plans for a new building.
Now one may start to wonder why exactly Hadrian was considered a good emperor in
the first place, given his propensity to eliminate those who slighted him.
But it was also Cassius DEO who came to his defense,
arguing that all of Hadrian's faults were atoned for,
by his careful oversight, his prudence, his munificence and his skill.
The historian posits that throughout his lengthy 21 year reign Hadrian did not
seek out war,
but terminated the conflicts already in progress restrict and disciplines, man,
he made sure his legions were the same and that they would never be guilty of
insulin sore in subordination.
He never deprived anyone of their wealth without cause, but quite the contrary,
often bestowed general sums upon citizens or even entire communities and that
he more than any other emperor before him assisted almost all of his allies and
subject cities giving to some, a water supply to others, harbors food,
public works, money and various honors.
And if you're going to bestow something amazing upon yourself, well,
let me tell you about today's sponsor dollar shave club,
dollar shave club covers all of your grooming needs, shower, oral care,
deodorant sands. Most importantly, shaving. Now, as you guys can probably tell,
I do not shave my beard. It can get a bit long, but I do shave my head.
And ever since I started using dollar shave club, that's going a lot better.
I used to use cheap raises, uh,
and they would just end up cutting up my head really badly,
but I didn't want to spend a fortune on the really expensive ones,
but they would save my head quite nicely.
Dollar shave club shaved my head nicely and then not mad expensive.
They sent me the ultimate shave starter sets,
which of course contains this razor.
And then it comes with these three little bottles right here.
And they've got a bunch of stuff. This one's first,
obviously perhaps grub slap bass on scrub it around, wash it off,
use the shave butter, boom, shave it,
wash it off and then apply some post-trade.
Do I like this because my head can get a little bit dry. Uh, generally,
especially after I've shaved, I slept that on and it's perfect. So look,
visit dollar shave club.com for slash biographics get the ultimate shave starter
set, but just $5.
And why not rounds out bank grooming routine by adding any other of their high
quality products after that,
the restock box ships at the regular price and Alaska back to the video.
[Inaudible].
We're given an outline of Hadrian's reign with the good and the bad,
but now let's get into more details here.
I've in Rome in 118 80 for his coronation,
he did the standard staff to get the public on his side. He organized games,
made donations, gave bonuses to soldiers, canceled debts, et cetera.
He also quote unquote suggested to ask the owners to give up his position as
Praetorian prefect and go into retirement in 119,
whether this was done as a gesture of Goodwill towards the Senate,
or because Hadrian genuinely had no involvement in the deaths of the four
senators.
We don't know that [inaudible] was replaced with two other men except to see as
Claris and Macias turbo.
One of Hadrian's first major acts as emperor was a ballsy one.
He reversed Trajan's policies in Western Asia and willingly surrendered.
The territories his predecessor had gained in Mesopotamia.
It wasn't a glorious move, but it was practical.
Hadrian understood that Rome might've been powerful enough to conquer the
region,
but did not have the soldiers and resources to keep it and maintain peace.
If he insisted on continuing Trajan's expansionist approach,
he would have had to deal with one rebellion after another. Instead,
what Hadrian liked was to use natural borders to consolidate the embar he
already had.
So he gave up room's claim to everything East of the affinities river.
This remains the Roman approach for the following for decades.
And so Rome wins a war against Patheos once again,
in 161 ID inside the empire Hadrian was enacting multiple reforms to benefit the
people of Rome, some which went against long established Roman traditions.
For example, when someone was charged with the major crime,
it was common to confiscate their estate. According to the new law,
if that person had children,
they were allowed to inherit a portion of their wealth Hadrian,
also reclassified middle class officials, soldiers, veterans,
and their families is on a [inaudible].
This is one of two categories of Roman citizens representing the high cost,
as opposed to humiliate berries,
which was the low-cost consisting of freed men and slaves.
The distinction was important because the higher-cost benefited from multiple
legal privileges, particularly when it came to criminal law,
they almost always received more lenient sentences while the cruelest punishment
such as being crucified or thrown to the beasts in the arena were reserved only
for the lower cost.
So while the wealthy enjoyed preferential treatment in most societies,
it was actually part of Roman law that they were granted these privileges.
And although Hadrian did not get rid of such concessions C at least made them
available to more groups of people. Some of the emperor's policies,
even benefited slaves as they limited the punishments that could be inflicted
upon them.
Hadrian made it illegal for citizens to kill their slaves just because they felt
like it. They could only do it.
If the slaves were found guilty of a capital offense,
when the slaves could not be sold to gladiator schools or brothels.
And unless again, it was punishment for a crime. They committed granted.
It's still not much in hindsight,
but it's more than most other emperors ever did to benefit the lowest class of
people in Rome.
[Inaudible].
Rain was characterized by one thing more so than anything else travel.
He traveled throughout his empire more than all the previous emperors going from
region to region preferring to see things for himself,
rather than relying on reports from others.
Other rulers usually upstage and Romans only left when it was time for war
Hadrian. On the other hand spent over half his rain outside Rome,
founding new cities and improving the ones that already existed.
He also gave plenty of attention to his military fortifications in order to
better protect his empire from external and internal threats.
You ordered the construction of new forts and garrisons had others moved to more
favorable positions.
And some had demolished Hadrian embarked on this tour of Zen power and 122
80 deep. His first stop was Britannia AKA the politic of great Britain,
which was a Roman province.
He ordered the construction of arguably the most famous structure that bears his
name. Hadrian's wall,
a 73 mile defensive fortification that traveled from the East to the West of the
province when it was finished at,
at 80 small forts called Mark castle plus 17 larger faults,
which we used to Garrison exhilarate soldiers from all over the end pop.
Initially it was abandoned right after Hadrian's death because the success of
wanted to build his own wall further up North into Scotland. However,
that second wall was subsequently also abandoned as the following emperor is
preferred to rely on hatred, which from that point on remained in use yeah,
over 300 years and large parts of the wall still do stand to this day
after Britannia Hadrian returned to mainland Europe and traveled through parts
of what is today, France and Spain, before sailing for North Africa,
all the trips themselves were not problematic.
The emperor had to deal with a few issues in Rome.
Pompa Platina the widow of Trajan and his former guardian had died.
So Hadrian made arrangements to have a day of, I built a temple in ironic.
Furthermore,
the emperor dismissed two of his close confidants from his inner circle for
allegedly behaving with great familiarity towards his wife's Bina.
They were septic.
He as Clarus one of the two Praetorian prefects and the historians Tonia is who
held the position of AB EPIs stewardess or the minister of letters who handled
the Imperial correspondence.
What happened to them after this point remains uncertain upon arriving in
Africa, Hadrian had to put down a rebellion by the Morse afterwards.
He cut his trip short when word reached him that Patheon,
might've been preparing for war again.
He hurried to Asia where he made sure that Roman defenses were up to snuff and
after discussions with the Patheon King Austra is the first ensured that there
would be peace between their embars,
at least for the time being while he was there,
Hadrian visited the Roman provinces in Asia minor.
And that is where he met Antinous by Sydney and youth that the Ambra fell in
love with.
He quickly became a favorite of Hadrian who first sent him to Rome to complete
his education. Then afterwards made him a part of his retinue.
His love has continued that journey throughout the empire.
The last stop before Hadrian finally returned to Rome in 126 D was Greece.
One of, if not his favorite place in the world, he spent almost a year there,
mostly in Athens taking part in their games and rituals, funding,
public works and festivals,
and even getting initiated in the Ellis Indian mysteries.
One of the most secretive religious rights of ancient Greece today,
there are still plenty of remnants left to remind the world of Hadrian's voyage.
There is an art of Hadrian in Athens.
There is an even more impressive one in Jordan there's Hadrian's gate in Turkey,
not to mention that he dedicated resources to finish or rebuild older structures
like the Roman Pantheon and the temple of Zeus in Athens after a couple of
years, spends in Rome,
Hadrian got restless again and sat out on another tour at 128.
This time starting with Greece, he then set off at Egypt.
Since you have to count his time in Africa short during his first voyage here,
tragedy befell the emperor in September or October, 130,
his lover Anthony has died apparently by falling and drowning in the river Nile.
There were whispers that he may have been murdered as part of a conspiracy
against Hadrian while Cassius Dio claims the young man sacrificed himself
willingly so that the gods may cure Hadrian of an unknown illness.
Whatever happens. The emperor was distraught over the death of the young man.
There's only him. He founded a new city on the riverbank way,
perished and named it Antonopoulos.
Even more Hadrian had his love of deified and declared a God,
a cult of worship developed around the man.
And although the emperor obviously encouraged and supported it spread throughout
the empire, even he probably did not expect it to become as big as it did.
The cult lasted for over 200 years after Trajan had died with over two dozen
temples dedicated to worship being built throughout the empire and thousands of
statues being made, bearing his likeness.
[Inaudible].
Well to enjoy a lengthly rule, mostly devoid of serious military conflicts,
but there is a giant exception and 132 80,
the Roman empire Forter abelian in Judea golds, the bar Barbara volts,
which dominated the last part of Hadrian's reign.
Tensions had been highly in that region for decades.
And this conflict is considered part of the larger Jewish Roman Wars,
which went on for 70 years as to what factors triggered this particular
uprising.
The most discernible motive seemed to be the construction of a new Roman city
called Eylea capita Lena, over the ruins of Jerusalem,
which included a temple dedicated to Jupiter built on temple mounts,
which was a Holy site for the Jewish people.
The rebellion was led by Simon bark. Hakuba hence the name of the revolts.
He wasn't just the military leader,
but he came to regard himself as a messianic figure who may have had up to
400,000 soldiers following him during the uprising. First,
the Romans did not expect that rebellion to grow as fast or be as ferocious as
it turned out to be. They were completely overwhelmed. And soon enough,
the rebels controlled the region.
This area in Judea basically became independent for over two years with rebels,
even striking their own currency.
Eventually though Hadrian called in one of his most accomplished generals,
sexist Julius Severus as well as reinforcements from other provinces.
The Romans started winning battles and forcing the Jewish rebels to withdraw or
until they had to fall back inside the ancient forty-five tower of the top.
What followed was a long siege, but Batar also fell eventually.
And Simon bark Hakuba died during that battle in 135.
A although his numbers can only serve as a rough estimate.
Cassius Dio claimed that over a thousand villages and outposts were raised
during the rebellion and roughly 580,000 men were killed in the fights.
Plus countless more perished of feminine disease or were sold as slaves.
[Inaudible].
Junior attends, aroma rounds,
134 Ady and never really strayed far outside its limits for the remainder of his
life. If the Historia or Augusta is to be believed,
he became more paranoid and violence. In his later years, putting to death,
influential men who he thought might be conspiring against him.
According to rumors, the emperor even poisoned his own wives,
Sabina who died in 136,
eight deep as Hadrian was getting older and began suffering from various
ailments. I have to consider his success up like Trajan beforehand.
He had no of his own.
So he would have to adopt someone and designate him as his app.
The first name that was thrown around was servi honors.
One of Hadrian's longest serving advisors.
He had been treated for years as the unofficial success.
I bet he was too elderly to become emperor.
He was fine two years old when he died in 136 Ady.
So instead the emperor thought about naming Sovi honest,
his grandson [inaudible] zap. However,
Hadrian soon changed his mind and went with a different man named Lucius
comedies. Not only that, but he has 70 honors and fosters put to death,
allegedly because they were displeased at his action.
What exactly this is supposed to mean? We're not sure.
Did they simply complain about the emperor or is this a nice way of saying that
they tried to stage a coup either way before being executed? So the honest,
allegedly got on his knees and said, as for Hadrian,
this is my only prayer that he may long for death, but be unable to die.
This became incredibly prophetic as Hadrian did indeed die,
a slow painful death and was prevented from committing suicide. Several times,
as far as the Zara was concerned, he adopted the name Lucius alias,
but this turned out to be a poor choice. His successor.
It was actually the son-in-law of Nigrini was one of the four senators killed at
the start of Hadrian's reign because of the, some,
see the choice from Hadrian as atonement for their death, suggesting that,
you know, I've been involved after all regardless, Lucius alias died in 138,
a D a few months before Hadrian. So the Umbra had to select another app.
This time he went with Antonius Pius,
who did indeed succeed him as Roman emperor Hadrian finally perished on July the
10th, 138 AED age 62. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below also, please.
Don't forget to check it out. Fantastic. Sponsor dollar shave club.
Thank you for watching.